[Applause]
[Music]
hi I'm chef Nick ham I'm a chef janila
chef/owner zico in New York City omakase
traditionally is driven by the chef and
mother nature it has to be driven by
seasonality or it really can't be
consider Mikasa the beauty of omakase
as a diner is the surprises and the
things that you look forward to at the
moment what we do here is we really
emphasize the course is to go one after
the other in a seamless way so that the
meal
it's a cohesive dinner I think the
counter is definitely an experience of
its own you do really get to see
everything there is no hiding there's no
walls between us you see it being cut
you see us being prepared and you see it
being served at that moment Jamie and I
we are into freshness you will see on a
daily basis fresh bluefin tuna - live
squid the squid is throbbing the bluefin
is just shining we think that it makes
the biggest difference so first we
prepare it solely needlefish I was just
stuff from like taking a skill out and
cut the head off and the catch off and
the pants off and when I started doing
sushi I dice a small piece and a little
soy sauce and you suggest on that and
then we do the tuna at total so we try
to get the tuna that is straight from
the resource to our restaurant we break
it down into maybe four or five
different preparation per night just a
simple total piece which is just gonna
melt in your mouth the cola
is a protein - not a parasite and I was
picking out the skin and the fat and I
separate line by line that I seen you in
the meat the membrane part we sear grill
in order to denature the toughness in it
then we also have the option of the
charcoal vintage on grilled Toro which
is from the collar part not how
chickpeas means from the spine there's a
perfect groove of meat in between the
tuna
which we scrape and get this beautiful
texture we use the abalone shell because
you know the tuna here is so much iron
and the shield will help and not oxidize
so quickly I personally like with a
little bit garlic on there Jimmy likes
garlic ginger Jimmy and I both made a
massive increase parking about food and
our philosophy on it and it seemed like
we had a lot in common
my training was a little bit more
traditional so a lot of it is
philosophical there's a lot of
discussion of colors and the way things
behave I've spent ten years with masa so
for me I learned not just the skills
that I practice today but the more
romantic side as well that's priceless
[Music]